I fact checked it and I thought, "Oh,
it's not true." Because I didn't see it
on Donald Trump's official Twitter X
thing, but it is true. Donald Trump made
a post and it is on actually the White
House X. This is the official White
House Twitter account less than 24 hours
ago. They posted a repost. This is
Donald Trump's official post. He posted
a picture of himself as the pope. Now,
some people are calling this blasphemous
and sacrilegious and all that. I don't
go that far because I don't think
there's anything um special about the
Catholic Church, the pope, any of that.
If you do studies on this, if you study
prophecy, you will find out that the
Catholic Church as a whole, the papal
system, is the Antichrist power. And if
if you've never heard that, if that
sounds crazy to you, we're going to go
through some of that right now. This is
his Instagram account. He actually
posted this almost a million and a half
likes in 23 hours. We went through this
with the Gaza video called Trump Gaza
and it showed a a golden idol and it was
this music video and everything. And we
did a a video on that showing how even
Trump fans are like, "Dude, like you're
making me change my mind about voting
for you." Like, and this person's like,
"You make it so hard to defend you
sometimes, but at the same time, they're
putting a laughing face." So, you know,
it's like, I don't know if people just
think this is trolling or it's funny.
Like, this man too funny. Joe Biden
could never funniest president ever. So,
people think this is funny. I don't I
don't understand
uh where the humor is in it. This is
Bible prophecy. The Roman Catholic
Church system. I'm not even talking
about those who are Roman Catholics.
There's a lot of well-meaning Roman
Catholic people who are just completely
deceived as to the system that they're
in. And I hope that this video right
here will open their eyes and that they
will come out of her my people. As
Revelation says, he's calling his
people. God doesn't have only people in
a certain denomination out there. He's
got people all over the world and he's
saying, "Come out of her. Do not be
deceived. Prophecy is coming true. And
I'm telling you now beforehand. This is
what's going to happen. The plagues are
going to come down. Come out of her, my
people, lest you taste the plagues. God
is pleading with his people. Now, check
this out. This is
Babylon over here. You see this is uh
Deeon and Babylon, the the god of
Babylon. And he has this Maltese cross
on his chest.
Ironically, the Pope has the same symbol
on his attire. This right here, you
can't see it in this picture because
it's kind of blurry, but you will see
this sunburst in a lot of Babylonian
art. So, we're already making
connections here. Check this out. This
is the god Deeon, the fish god Deeon of
Babylon. He wore this fish head that
came down in a cape. And it's the same
outfit that you see the popes wear
today. This is not some coincidence.
This is not like you can't excuse this
any any other way. What's crazy is that
the Catholic Church, the Catholic
denomination is the world's largest
denomination. We've done videos on this
before. I don't want to have to fact
check and prove all this stuff to you
guys, but if this is all new to you,
please check out this video right here
called Who's Next? This video went way
more in depth about the Catholic Church
being the antichrist system that it is
Babylon. Not remember that Babylon
hasn't existed for generations and yet
revelation talks about Babylon talks
about Babylon is fallen and come out of
her and all this stuff because all
prophecies that God has given were
written in symbols. And so when you have
uh Joseph dreaming about skinny cows
eating fat cows and all this stuff that
wasn't real. It was symbolic. It was
about a famine. When you see Daniel
having a dream or a vision about beasts
rising out of the the sea, it wasn't
about beasts. It was about kingdoms.
When you see Peter having a vision about
unclean animals coming down in a sheet
and God says, um, take up and eat. And
Peter says, I've never eaten anything
unclean. And he says, I don't know what
this vision means. And you keep reading
a little further and you'll see that uh
he has an encounter with a gentile and
that's that was what the prophecy was
about. And he says God said do not call
any man in unclean. So God's always
giving visions in these symbolic
prophetic symbols. And when you read
Revelation there's not really going to
be a woman, a harlot drinking blood
sitting on a seven-headed dragon.
There's not really going to be a woman
dressed in white standing on the moon
clothed with the sun. These are symbols.
So when it talks about Babylon, it's
talking about not literal Babylon that
doesn't exist anymore. It's not talking
about Iraq or something like that. It's
talking about this false Christian
denomination that's a a church and
state, a mingling of church and state.
That's the iron and clay. That's the
feet of that statue of
Nebuchadnezzar. When you hear Israel,
it's not talking about the nation of
Israel. There's neither Jew nor Greek.
We're all one in Christ Jesus. The Bible
says there is no God is not a racist.
There is no such thing as uh bloodlines
that are just going to be like God's
chosen people. Israel is us. You've been
grafted in. There's neither Jew nor
Greek. We're all one in Christ Jesus. So
when it talks about Israel, it's talking
about God's people. Us. We are God's
people. If the president is quote
unquote joking about being the next
pope, he's saying he's the next king of
Babylon. Prophecy says that America is
going to join hands with the first
beast, which is Rome. America is the
second beast. That might sound totally
crazy. You probably never heard that
before. Maybe you haven't heard that
before. Look it up. Look into it. The
second beast is a beast that rises
sometime in the 1700s and it comes up
because what's the newest nation in the
world? America. It rises out of the
earth which is a desolate place because
the waters the Bible says the waters are
peoples and multitudes and tongues and
all that. Well, this beast rises out of
the earth sometime after the fall of
Rome. So, it has to be sometime in the
1700s. America is the new world
superpower that rose up out of a not so
populated area. There was some natives
here and it it speaks like a dragon. It
speaks like Satan. It speaks like Rome,
but it has horns like a lamb. So, it's
got this facade of being a Christian
nation, a lamblike nation, but it speaks
like a dragon. And what does it say?
That the second beast will cause all to
worship the first beast. So, America
will cause all to worship Rome. It's a
deep study. If you guys are tripping
right now, look into this stuff. But we
see that Trump already alluded to him
being the king of Babylon, right?
Because the golden image in the Bible
was the the dream that Nebuchadnezzar
had a dream of a statue that was of him,
but he was only a head of gold in that
statue. And the head of gold represented
Babylon. But Daniel said, "No, these
other kingdoms are actually going to
conquer you. It's going to be Meo Persia
is going to conquer you. Then Greece is
going to conquer you. Then Rome is going
to you. Then it's going to be the
feet of iron and clay, which is a a
Roman church state system, which we know
is the papal system. That that's
dressed in purple and scarlet decked
with gold and precious stones. You can
look up, Google purple scarlet gold
church, and all you're going to find is
pictures of the Vatican because they are
the city that sits on seven hills, which
is Rome, the the beast with seven heads
or seven hills. All this stuff is out
there. go watch our video about who's
next, who's the next um pope. So, this
isn't the first time Trump is now saying
he's going to be the next pope
symbolically through these images. He's
got this image of himself as a golden
statue. What is it? Why does he keep
doing this? Why does he keep using AI to
create images of him as the king of
Babylon or the king of Rome?
because there's something called
predictive programming and they you see
this stuff in movies um where they
predict some future event and things
like 9/11 and COVID and all these things
were predicted in movies over and over
and over again years before it ever
happened. And this is a satanic ritual.
This is an occult ritual brainwashing
the masses subtly and subliminally
desensitizing you to the truth that is
coming. Um, I I got all these tabs here
and I'm trying to keep up with them, but
okay. So, we saw Trump is the next pope.
Trump is the king of Babylon, the golden
image. Now, what does this guy say?
Through your leadership, you embody the
values of our Christian faith and love
for the gospel. You remind me of the
great Roman Emperor, Constantine the
Great.
And the whole crowd cheers. This guy
said, "You remind me of the great Roman
Emperor
Constantine." Okay, so now he's
comparing himself to the next pope.
Roman pope, uh, Babylon, the golden
image. This guy is saying he's
Constantine. What about Cyrus? Cyrus was
the king of Persia. Well, we know that
Persia was the one that conquered
Babylon. Babylon, Meo Persia. Well, do
you know that Trump's face is on a coin
for Israel right now? right next to
Osiris. This isn't just some Trump
fan-made stuff. This is on
templecoins.com. This was made by
Israel. This is a coin made by Israel.
This isn't, like I'm saying, this is not
Trumpers. They're putting his face right
next to Cyrus. Now, why would Trump be
compared to Cyrus, who was the one who
conquered? When you think of these
rulers, you got
Nebuchadnezzar, Cyrus,
um Alexander the Great was Greece, and
then you had Rome,
Constantine. Right now, he's already
fulfilling like three of these. I mean,
Nebuchadnezzar, the golden image, Cyrus,
he's on the coin, and then Constantine,
the guy just called him Constantine, and
he's sitting as the pope. So he's he's
already considering himself three of the
four world rulers so far. He hasn't
compared himself to Alexander the Great
that I know of. So what language do the
Romans speak? Latin and Greek. So I'm
putting the pieces together. Okay, he's
he's the next pope. He's called they're
calling him Constantine. He's on the
coin of Cyrus, Nebuchadnezzar, the
golden image. But what about if he's
associated himself with Rome, Roman
Catholicism, all that, and you look up
in the Latin what the word MAGA means,
make America great again, it means
witch. So Trump's whole slogan, I mean,
he's got he's got all his fans that are
literally like cult members wearing MAGA
witch. He's seducing them with his
spell. And it it's not just Trump. It's
not like Trump is this um just villain.
He works for someone else. He works for
Satan. He works for the new world order.
He's a puppet. Trump is not a messiah.
Trump's not going to save the day. He's
not any different than any other
politician. It's a different mask. Every
four years, we put on a different mask.
And the pendulum swings back and forth.
The right side gets their guy, then the
left side gets their guy, and the right
side gets their guy. All the while the
the agenda is rolling out, the new world
order agenda, and it's this whole order
out of chaos, two steps forward, one
step back. So, when right when there's
about to be an uprising, when the people
are like, "We're sick of this." Oh, you
get your guy. And they're like, "Oh,
good." Well, Trump comes in and he says,
"You know what? We're going to ban all
the um we're going to ban fluoride.
We're going to ban uh food dyes. We're
going to get rid of all the woke
culture." And everybody's just like,
"This is great. Gas prices are better.
all this stuff. Everybody's letting
their guard down and they're thinking
everything's good. Well, that's the one
step back, two steps forward. The agenda
is still two steps forward. Just because
you took one step back and you get rid
of poisons in our food and say that you
shouldn't chop the genitals off of
children, that's really not doing much.
That's normal. So as we're going one
step back to normaly, we're going two
steps forward into the new world order
where he's saying we're going to unroll
Stargate where AI is going to govern the
entire world through surveillance.
24-hour surveillance governed by AI.
This is what Trump's doing the first
month he was in. I mean, Elon's like his
sidekick. And when when the Democrats
were in, everybody was like against
Elon. No, he wants to microchip our
brains and all this stuff. But now that
he's sidekicks with Trump, everybody's
like, "Oh, cool. Elon's great. Well,
Elon is the richest man in the world. He
is an elitist. His mother is a satanic
as it comes. So, the Bible talks about
there's coming an image of the beast.
And I know a lot of people have a lot of
crazy ideas out there. I used to believe
this when I was um coming to this type
of truth. these when I was really
studying prophecy in 2012, I was like,
man, the the feet of iron and clay,
that's going to be a mingling of man and
machine. This is transhumanism, iron and
clay. We are clay, right? And and this
is going to be this transhuman thing.
And then the image that you that comes
to life, that's going to be like AI or
some kind of supercomput or something
crazy. I thought all that stuff and then
I really started studying line upon
line, letting the Bible interpret
itself. When the Bible says that beasts
are kingdoms and all this stuff, it was
starting to make sense. An image of the
beast, the beast is a kingdom. So if you
have an image, you're you're talking
about a mirror replica of a kingdom. The
second beast, the second kingdom,
America, is going to make an image or
become a mirror replica of the first
beast, Rome. And you look at America.
This is America. That's Washington DC
with the dome and the obelisk. Now, did
it make a mirror image of the first
beast, Rome with the dome and the
obelisk right here. Look at the obelisk
is right here. It might be hard to see
for you guys, but there it is right here
in the sun wheel because this is all
about sun worship. All roads lead to
Rome,
right? All roads lead to Rome.
Everything is pointing back to sun
worship because that's Satan's biggest
deception, bringing everybody back to
the sun. It's going to be a one world
religion where well, every every
religion is just a way to God, right?
That's what the Pope said before he
died. He said, well, he had these
commercials where um you know, Muslims
and Buddhists and Jews and Christians
all put their relics together and they
said, "We all serve the same God, love."
And then before he died, he gave a
speech that said, you know, there's many
ways to God. It's like different
languages. God has like different
languages to him. And some of it is
there all these different religions. It
could be Buddhism. It could be uh
Judaism. It could be Muslim. But they
all go to God. This is the one world
religion that's coming. The coexist
movement. Revelation 13:15 says, "And he
had power to give life unto the image."
This isn't talking about some statue
that's going to come to life. This is
all symbolic. Remember, there's not
really going to be a woman standing on
the moon clothed with the sun. This is
symbolic language. The beast is a
kingdom. And an image of the beast would
be an exact replica of this kingdom and
it's going to come to life, meaning it's
going to become a great nation. And it
says, "And he had power to give life
unto the image of the beast, that the
image of the beast should both speak and
cause as many as would not worship the
image of the beast to be killed." Now,
is this saying that we're going to all
be that people are all going to be
bowing down before an image, a statue?
No. Because it's talking about the image
of the beast, and a beast is a kingdom.
So this is
saying that all the world is going to
bow down to the exact mirror image of
Rome. This is what it's saying that the
world is going to worship the image of
the beast which we just saw in this
picture is Washington DC which is
America. It's just this it's this one
world religion. That's what this is
talking about that all the world is
going to worship according to this one
world religion. Now, I know people have
confusion about what's the mark of the
beast. Is it a microchip? It says you
can't buy or sell without it. It's got
to be a microchip, right? That's what I
used to believe as well, but when you
really study this stuff out, you will
see the truth of this. I want to go into
a little bit of this because it says, "I
stood on the sand of the sea. I saw a
beast rise out of the sea having seven
heads, 10 horns, and upon his horns, 10
crowns, and upon his heads the name of
blasphemy." This is the first beast.
This is Rome. This is the papacy. When
it says seven heads, it means seven
hills or seven mountains. When you look
up, what is the city of seven hills?
Boom. Rome. What is the purple and
scarlet church? It's the Vatican. So, it
says, I saw one of them as a its head. I
saw one of its heads as it were wounded
to death and its deadly wound was
healed. This is talking about at one
point in time the Roman Empire fell. It
suffered a fatal wound. But has that
wound healed? Yes. All the leaders of
the world go over and kiss the finger of
the pope and his ring and they bow and
they shake hands. All this stuff. The
the beast's deadly wound has been
healed. And they worshiped the dragon
and gave power unto the beast and they
worshiped the beast. Look, it says they
worshiped the dragon. That's Satan. When
you are worshiping anything other than
God, then you are worshiping Satan. And
it says they worship the dragon which
gave power unto the beast because the
beast the dragon Satan he's the god of
this world. When you worship him you're
giving him power to have more power. And
it says the power unto the beast. And
they worshiped the beast saying who is
like unto the beast who is able to make
war with him. That's what we say today.
We're like nobody can make war with
America. We're the superpower.
We've we've defeated everyone that's
come to war with us.
And there was given unto him a mouth
speaking great things and blasphemies
and power was given unto him to continue
40 and two months. Now this actually is
talking about when it says who can make
war into the beast. This is talking
about Rome. This isn't talking about
America yet. But that's the same thing
that people that's emerging of America
and Rome. Verse 11. And I beheld another
beast coming out of the earth. This is
not the water. The water was great
multitudes of people and tongues and
many nations. This is coming out of the
earth. He had two horns like a lamb,
like a Christian nation, and he spake as
a dragon. He made laws and he uh ruled
as Satan or as Rome even because the
Bible talks about a a dragon
symbolically that water spewed out of
his mouth to try and and killed Christ,
but his mother Mary fled from the
persecution of Rome into the wilderness.
So that who who came after Jesus? Rome.
So the dragon can also represent Rome
symbolically and he we're talking about
the second beast that just came out of
the earth. He which is America and
America exercise all the power of the
first beast Rome. America exercises all
the power of Rome and causes the earth
and them which dwell in there to worship
Rome whose deadly wound was healed. So
this is why America is considered the
false prophet because the false prophet
and the second beast are one and the
same. What does a what does a prophet
do? A prophet points you to worship
somebody else. Right? So America is
causing the earth to worship the first
beast. America's the false prophet,
saying, "Everyone worship Rome." And he
doeth great wonders, and make fire come
down from heaven and the earth in the
sight of men. And he deceiveth them that
dwell on the earth, that he should make
an image. We just got into
that. All right. And he causes all, both
small and great, rich and poor, free and
bond, that's everyone, every man, to
receive a mark in their right hand and
in their foreheads. and that no man
might buy or sell save he had that mark
he had the mark or the number of the
beast or the number of his name. Here's
wisdom. Let him that hath understanding
count the number of the beast for it is
the number of a man and his number is
6003 scoring six or 666. Please if this
is all new to you watch that video.
Watch the video called who's next. It's
just it's in the live section. When you
go to our channel, please click on the
live. Most of our videos are live. We
have a couple under the live under the
video section, but most of our stuff is
under live. I think that's why people
can't find our stuff. We proved that 666
is the pope. Any pope, not not Francis,
but every pope that puts that crown on
that says vicarious fle day, which is
Latin for the substitute of Christ on
earth. It equals up when you count the
number of the beast, it equals up to
666. And it's the number of a man. That
man being the pope. Now, when it says
this one verse that says you can't buy
or sell, that's it. Everybody makes a
whole belief system that this is a
microchip because you can't buy or sell
without it. Not being able to buy or
sell is a punishment. If you don't
worship the beast and his image, you
will be punished. And one of those
punishments is you won't buy. you won't
be able to buy or sell. So that could be
a microchip, that could be debit cards,
that could be social credit, it could be
just some digital currency that's not an
implant. It has nothing to do with being
in your forehead or in your hand. The
mark that's in your forehead or hand is
about worship and we're going to prove
that. So here's another another image of
Trump associated with Rome. There's a
project out there saying thirdterm
project. They want to make Trump
president again. and a third term. Now,
look at this very Naziish uh phoenix
here with a halo over his head or a
crown. I guess it's a crown cuz it's cut
off. And Trump as a Caesar, a Roman
Caesar. So, this imagery, this
predictive programming keeps coming up
over and over and over that Trump is
going to be our king. Trump's going to
get a third term. Trump is like a Roman
Caesar. He's the next pope. We're going
to be bowing down to his golden image.
But I think this is all
propaganda. Predictive programming. I
asked I asked Google what is predictive
programming so I could just give a a
condensed version. It says predictive
programming is a concept primarily
discussed within conspiracy theory
circles. Yeah, it doesn't really exist,
right? This that suggest the elements of
future events are intentionally embedded
within fictional media like movies,
television shows, books, and video
games. Here's a breakdown of the
concept. media media creators
potentially at at the behest of powerful
groups like governments or elites subtly
encode future events or social changes
into entertainment. The goal is to
gradually desensitize the public to
these events making them more accepting
and less resistant when they actually
occur in reality. This normalization
process could involve depicting
dystopian scenarios, social unrest,
social advancements, or other
significant shifts such as aliens and
UFOs and all that stuff. Right? So,
that's the little breakdown of what
predictive programming is. And I believe
that's what all this predictive
programming is. all this stuff about
Trump being the pope, Trump having a a
golden image, uh him being like Cyrus
and him being a Roman Caesar. Now,
Constantine, I showed you the image. I
showed you Oh, I showed you the video
where that guy said, "You are like the
great Roman Constantine." Who is
Constantine? What was he known for? So,
that's what I I asked. What religious
law did Constantine enforce? Because we
know there's going to be a religious law
coming. We know that the Bible says that
he will cause all both free and bonds
slave all that the whole world to
worship. That means religion, right? So
we know that the second beast America is
going to cause the whole world to
worship a certain way. How do you do
that? Through religious laws. So if he's
being considered Constantine and a Roman
emperor and all this stuff, what kind of
religious laws did Constantine enforce?
Constantine the Great enacted several
religious laws that favored
Christianity,
Christianity, Catholic Christianity,
paganism,
Babylon, and suppressed pagan practices.
That's what they believe. But notice
Constantine, he pretended or maybe he
was truly deceived. I don't know. He
said that he converted to Christianity
and he was going to stop persecuting
Christians. And yes, you can worship,
but you're not going to worship on the
Sabbath day because that's Judaizing.
You're going to keep the venerable day
of the sun. And you can worship in these
temples full of idols, but uh just don't
think of them as Jupiter, Saturn, and
Mars. think of them as Rome or think of
them as Peter, Paul and John, right? And
so that's why we have this messed up
system called Catholicism that's full of
paganism. One key law was the edict
edict of Milan in 313 which granted
religious tolerance ending the
persecution of Christians and allowing
freedom of worship. All right, sounds
good so far. He also issu issued decrees
that favored Christian observances like
Sunday. What are they talking about?
Christian observances in
3:13. No Christian was ever keeping
Sunday until this happened. And you guys
might be triggered by that. You might
show some verses that say, "Oh, they
were breaking bread together on the
first day of the week and all this
stuff." Yeah, breaking bread together.
You can do that any day. It actually
says they broke bread together daily.
There's there's like three verses that
talk about the first day of the week.
They're all easily explained. One is
talking about uh Paul saying, "Have your
collections ready on the first day of
the week." But this was a letter to the
city that he was going through on the
way to the temple. And he said, "Have
your tithes basically ready for me
because I'm coming through your city on
the first day of the week and I'll take
it to the temple." It could have been a
Wednesday, but it happened to be the
first day of the week. Had nothing to do
with passing an offering plate around on
Sunday. And then there's another one
that talks about um they were they were
in the upper chamber on the first day of
the week and there were many lights on
in the upper chamber and he had been
Paul had been preaching a long- winded
sermon and a guy in the the window fell
out of the window to his death and Paul
went down there and raised him up. Now
think about the scenario in the Bible
sunset is a new day. So, if it's saying
there were many lights in the upper
chamber, that means it's nighttime. And
it says upon the first day of the week,
meaning it has just become Sunday. The
lights are on. It's just become Sunday
upon the first day of the week. And he
had been long- winded preaching so long
that somebody fell out the window. This
means that Paul was preaching a long-
winded Sabbath service that continued
into Sunday. Has nothing to do with
changing God's fourth commandment,
getting rid of it. Jesus said, "I've
come not to destroy the law or the
prophets. Think not." He said, "If you
break one of the least commandments, you
will be called the least. But those who
keep the commandments and teach others
to do so will be called great in the
kingdom of heaven." Okay. All that to
say that Constantine enforced a Sunday
worship, a venerable day of the sun. And
here you will see that in 3:21 AD, Roman
in Emperor Constantine decreed the that
Sunday, which he referred to as the
venerable day of the sun, should be a
day of rest from labor and all judges,
city dwellers, and craftsmen. So he
enforced sun worship, the day of the
sun. And he outlawed Judaizing. He
outlawed keeping the Sabbath.
So, check this out. This was on
Newsweek. This is a short uploaded on
Newsweek's YouTube channel. And look
what they titled it. Trump says to
forget about separation of church and
state for faith office. That's what they
titled. I mean, I could I could see a
title a caption like that coming from
Christian groups that understand
prophecy this way. But for Newsweek to
make that what the title says, Trump
says to forget about separation of
church and state for faith offices.
Listen, they work right out of the White
House. They've never done that. That's
never been done before. No other
president allowed that, I think. You
know, they say
separation, they say separation between
church and state, they told me. I said,
"All right, let's forget about that for
one time." We said, "Really? The
separation state?" They told me. I said,
"All right, let's forget about that for
one. Let's forget about that for one
time. That's crazy. We said really the
separation. I don't know. Is that a good
thing or a bad thing? I'm not sure. But
whether there's separation or not, you
guys are in the White House where you
should be. I created a historic Okay,
that's crazy. Super prophetic. We now
have a president who compares himself to
the Pope and Roman Constantine and Cyrus
and Nebuchadnezzar. And we know that
we're racing towards a time where
there's going to be a one world
religion. And now he's saying separation
of church and state. Let's do away with
that for once. Let's get rid of that.
And the crowd is cheering. They have no
clue what's going
on. So what are blue laws? Blue laws,
also known as Sunday laws or Sabbath
laws, are restrictions or bans on
certain commercial and entertainment
activities on Sundays, often with a
historical religious basis. These laws
aim to promote a day of rest and
religious observance. There are other
ones too. You look up um green sabbath
and here's a green sabbath project.net
when you check it out. Look the green
sabbath project. Is there nothing you
can do about the environment? Nothing
may be the one best thing you can do.
One day every week do nothing. So, there
are movements out there right now that
are saying to help the environment and
notice this hexog, this six-pointed star
right here on top of the globe earth.
Their logo is a hexog. That's one of the
most occult symbols in the world. Don't
think that this is a star of David. It
is not. But this organization and others
are saying, look, to help the
environment from climate change, which
is bogus, they're saying do nothing one
day a week. So, what day would they
pick? It says, "Take a weekly day of
rest. Make it a real Sabbath for both
you, for you, for Earth. Don't drive.
Don't shop. Don't build. Take a walk.
Eat with friends. Play or read with your
kids. Sing. Meditate." Interesting.
Celebrate
contentment. Look, I believe we should
keep a day of rest, but I don't believe
we should be enforcing it by law. Unless
you're a Christian and you're saying,
"God commanded me to rest on the on the
seventh day of the week in the fourth
commandment, I will do it."
No human institution should be enforcing
any religious laws. And yet here we see,
and they keep calling it the Sabbath.
Actually, in here it says the uh
Sabbath. We see Shabbat. We see the
biblical Sabbath. But what day are they
actually going to be keeping this on?
This is a Sunday law here. Every Sunday,
if if we were going to pick a day to
keep, the obvious day would be Sunday.
They already do it. Mail doesn't run.
DMV doesn't run. The government shuts
down. Everything's already keeping
Sunday. Blue laws are already a law.
They might not be enforced everywhere,
but blue laws are already on the books
for every state. Now, look at this. This
is a website called today I
foundout.com. Has nothing to do with
religion. Nothing. This is just
historical fact. Look what they say.
What are blue laws? Jyn, somebody named
Jyn asked, "What are blue laws and how
did they come to be?" And it says,
"Rooted in the basic uh Christian tenant
that Sunday is to be a reserved be
reserved as the Lord's day. Blue laws
were originally enacted." So check this
out because this is going to help you
understand about not being able to buy
or sell. People think it has to be a
microchip. currency is not the mark of
the beast. God isn't damning people to
hell because they pay for their
groceries a certain way. And I know that
might sound controversial or triggering,
but the thing is, think about this.
People believe that no one can pluck you
out of the hands of God. No one can
jeopardize your salvation. No man can
jeopardize your salvation. Well, imagine
if you're a Christian that gets rounded
up in the last days and thrown in prison
and they forcefully jam a microchip
under your skin to track you. What if
babies are being born and they're when
they take those babies away and start
giving them all their shots, they're
jamming microchips under their skin? The
Bible says if you have that mark, you
are damned. Now, if it's a microchip,
this is saying that any man could
literally take away your salvation. You
are you are unredeemable because a
microchip has been shoved under your
skin. It's
nonsense. Now, a microchip could help
enforce this system of worship. It look
our phones, everything, everything that
we have where we're checking in and all
this stuff. This is desensitizing us.
This is preparing us for that system.
When you go to a restaurant, you check
in and you save 10% off your meal.
You're already starting to participate
in the future system, the social credit
score. Did you go to church this Sunday?
You better have had a good excuse. If
you didn't, you must have been deathly
sick. Now, you want your social credit
score to be up, right? You have to go to
church to be a good citizen. That's what
social credit score is all about.
They're doing this in China. If you're a
good citizen, you have a higher credit
score and you can do things. But if
you're not a good citizen, well, not
going to church, that sounds like a bad
citizen, right? You need to go to church
to get your score up. So, all of this
stuff has been how they're doing it.
When people see that verse, you can't
buy or sell, they think this is the mark
of the beast. It's not. It says if they
don't take the mark, then they won't be
able to buy and sell because there's
multiple forms of punishment. One, you
can't buy or sell. Another says you'll
be thrown in prison 10 days. And another
one says that they will be beheaded, the
saints that were beheaded for overcoming
the mark of the beast. Now look, you're
going to see those three things in
historical facts of how they enforced
the Sunday laws. The first blue laws,
although not called that at the time,
was enacted in colonial Virginia in
1610. That's how long ago?
1610. And it mandated church attendance
at both morning and afternoon services
on Sundays. They mandated Sunday,
mandate Sunday. In 1610, long before
microchip, a firsttime offender lost his
provision of
allowance. He lost his ability to buy or
sell. You didn't go to church? Well, you
don't get your allowance. Apparently,
they must have had some kind of system
where everyone got this like weekly
allowance, and if you didn't go to
church, boom, you can't buy or sell.
Long before microchip. Long before a
cell phone, long before social credit
scores, for the whole week, it says you
lost your provision for the whole week.
That's the first offense. Those who
committed a second offense in addition
to losing his allowance. So, you're not
going to get that allowance
again whipped. Persecution. Thrown in
prison 10 days. Right? So, now we see
you can't buy or sell. Persecution. The
third violation was supposedly punished
by death. though there is debate over
whether accounts of early blue laws were
in some cases exaggerated or not. So
they're like saying we don't know if it
was punishable by death probably because
everyone conformed. People like okay
I've already had my allowance taken away
for not going to church this week. The
second week I was no allowance and beat.
You can't go that long without food or
being able to buy and being beaten. They
probably went to church the next time.
But there it is. Can't buy or sell.
persecution and death. This is exactly
what Revelation says is going to happen.
Now, what I think is interesting is they
are already setting up confusion on what
is the seventh day of the week. I mean,
I I already hear people say that now.
They're like, "Well, what how do we know
what day is the seventh day of the
week?" Look at any old dictionary, any
encyclopedia from the past. They stop
they stop printing these things. I
wonder why. So that they can control and
and change everything. If everything's
digital, if all books are digital, you
can change it. Now, when I asked what is
the seventh day of the week, it says the
seventh day of the week is
Saturday. That's true. But when I scroll
down and I see this that says Sunday is
the seventh day of the week. True or
false? It says, how can we be sure
Saturday is the seventh day of the
week?
Sunday? Wait a minute. Wikipedia says
Sunday is the seventh and last day of
the week. Are you believing this
already? Right now, the the tool that we
all use Siri and all these and Google
and all that when you ask what is the
seventh day of the week, it's saying
Sunday, the seventh and last day of the
week. But that's not true. Look at any
calendar. It's the first day of the
week. This is preparation for the beast
system. the one world religion is
coming. Look again, se Sunday is the
seventh day of the
week. So they're setting up confusion.
The word Babylon means confusion. If
this isn't making sense to you about
well how what it says a mark. A mark is
that's got to be like an implant right
in your forehead or in your hand. It
says a mark. You you can't change it. It
says a mark. Okay. Remember it's all
symbolic. God's people are going to be
sealed in their forehead, right? A seal
is a st a stamp in wax. Are God's people
really going to be walking around with a
seal in their forehead? And people say,
"No, no, it God's seal is symbolic, is
spiritual, but Satan's mark is a
counterfeit and it's it's literal and
physical." That's not what That's not
what the Bible says. Let's study line
upon line. Here a little, there a little
from the mouth of two or three
witnesses. So, let's look for it. It is
a counterfeit. Satan's mark is a
counterfeit of God's sign or seal. It's
the same word. When you look at sign or
seal in the Hebrew, it means mark. It's
the same exact word. I can show you
that. Strong's Hebrew
226 o sign.
Mark. Mark, right? Sign and mark. Sign
and mark. It's the same word. All right.
Now, I want to show you where God's seal
is. Because God's sign is his mark. And
where is it at? Deuteronomy 11 verse 18.
Therefore shall ye lay up these my words
which are in your heart. What words of
God are in our heart? What does he say?
I've written my commandments on your
heart. Right? My law is written in your
heart and in your soul and bind them for
a sign or mark upon your where hand that
they may be as frontlets between your
eyes in your forehead. So God's sign
which is his mark is in between our
foreheads in between our eyes and our
foreheads and in our hand and it's his
law. It's his commandment. That's one
verse. Here's another one. Deuteronomy
6:8. And thou shalt bind them for a sign
upon thine hand that they may be as
frontless behind eyes. Let's look at the
context here. And these words which I
command thee this day shall be in thine
heart. So what what is God's commands
that are on our heart, right? His
commandments, his laws that thou shalt
bind them as a sign upon thine hand.
They shall be as frontless between your
eyes. So God's commandments are to be in
the beliefs of our mind. We should
believe them with all our heart and in
our mind and we should do them with the
works of our hands. The Bible says, "And
everything you do, do it. Everything
your hand does, do it unto the Lord."
The works of your hand. Obedience, trust
and obey. Trust and obey. Believe and
do. He says, "Don't just be hearers of
the word only, but be doers of the
word." These are all scriptures. Now,
Exodus 13:9 says, "And it shall be for a
sign or a mark unto thee upon thine
hand, and a memorial between thine eyes,
that what the Lord's law may be in thy
mouth, for a strong hand hath the Lord
brought thee out of Egypt." So God's
commandments, which are written on our
hearts, are to be in our foreheads and
in our hand. And Satan's counterfeit is
another. It's another form of worship
that's in your beliefs and in your hand.
Some people will not believe in the new
world one world religion. They won't.
They'll say, "I know this is wrong." So,
they're not going to take it in the
forehead. There'll be a lot of people
that believe it. They'll say, "This is a
this is a
revival. This is coexist. This is love."
And they're going to believe it. They're
going to take it in their
forehead. Those who
compromise, they'll say, "I don't
believe it.
But I got to do it. I have to just
simply do it because it's going to
preserve my life and the life of my
family. So, I'm going to take it in the
hand. They do it, but they don't believe
it. What? Shadrach, Meshach, and Abedneo
are a parallel for us. There was an
image and they said, "We refuse to break
God's second commandment. We will not
bow." They didn't believe it. They
didn't believe in Nebuchadnezzar's
statue, but they wouldn't even simply
bow their bodies because it would break
God's second commandment. They wouldn't
take it in the hand. We refuse. Throw us
in the fire. They could have simply
bowed their bodies and said, "Look, I
don't believe this thing. But if I just
bow my body, big deal. I won't be thrown
in the fire." They kept God's commands.
They were sealed because the seal is in
your forehead. the beliefs of your mind
because belief, you don't work your way
to heaven. You don't get it in the hand.
But if you believe it, you'll do it
automatically. You automatically there's
there is no God's sign in the hand in
the last days. The seal of God is in the
forehead because if you believe it,
you're going to do it. And I showed all
the scriptures. I showed three verses in
the book of Revelation alone that says
God's people who overcome the mark of
the beast keep the commandments of God.
They're the the remnant saints that keep
the commandments of God and have right
to the tree of
life. Now, there were a group of people
that Jesus always called them out, the
Pharisees, right? You guys are religious
Pharisees, legalists. You're doing it
wrong. You're reading the scriptures,
but you're doing it in outward works.
When I said my sign in your forehead, I
did not mean to put a box on your head
and a box on your hand or on your arm.
This is the wrong way to do it. This is
what I'm saying. The book of Revelation
is not physical. It's not literal. It's
symbolic. We have a leader right now
who's saying, "I'm the next pope." With
predictive programming, he's putting
himself as the next pope. He's
associating himself with
Babylon. And he's making himself like
Nebuchadnezzar again, Babylon. And what
does the scripture say about Babylon in
the book of Revelation? Babylon the
Great. Babylon the Great is fallen. Is
fallen. It's fallen. It's corrupt.
Babylon is corrupt. Babylon is that
Catholic church system, that Roman
church state system.
It's fallen. If you're in that system,
get out right now. It's a fallen system.
It's become the habitation of devils and
the hold of every foul spirit and the
cage of every unclean and hateful bird.
I think it's interesting that the book
of Revelation still calls animals clean
and unclean. Let that one sink in. For
all nations have drunk of the wine or
the wrath of a fornication. Fornication.
It's spiritual fornication on God. If
you're in that system, you have been
drunk by her false doctrines, the wine
that's causing you to fornicate against
God. Spiritual fornication, because
we're supposed to be in a marriage
covenant with God, and the kings of the
earth have committed fornication with
her, all the world, rich and poor, all
the kings of the
earth. And the merchants of the earth
were are wax rich through the abundance
of her delicacies. But this is the part
I want you to hear. And I heard another
voice come from heaven saying, "Come out
of her, my people." God is pleading with
his people, "Come out of this system,
please, that ye be not partakers of her
sins, and that ye receive not her
plagues." I hope this was eye openening
for you. I hope if this was the first
time you ever heard this, please reach
out to us. We are a ministry. We're not
just YouTubers. We interact with people.
Email us at
info@canatruth.org. If this is the first
time you ever heard this, please give
this video a thumbs up. It really helps
this video get into the algorithm. We
have been we're not monetized. We've
applied twice for monetization and been
denied by YouTube by saying we are
harmful content. You can only apply
every two months and every time they say
we're harmful content. The reason we
want monetization is so we can show our
t-shirts at the bottom so we can get
super chats. We actually don't want you
to be exposed to commercials every video
we have. So, we're thankful that we're
not exposing anyone to commercials, but
we can't do this without you. We are
self-supporting ministry. We are
donationbased ministry. If you want to
support this ministry, you can do so by
going to
candidtruth.org. We got many different
ways to give. Thank you so much for
those of you who are giving. We see you.
We love you. We thank you. We're giving
you a shout out right now. God bless you
guys for giving to this ministry. If you
like t-shirts, you can go to
cantruth.org. We got awesome t-shirts on
there that you can buy and we get about
$5 per shirt that sells on
there. Like I said, give this video a
thumbs up. Click that subscribe button
if you're not a subscriber yet. Share
this video with all your family and
friends because this is what's happening
right now. And I forgot to mention, I
don't believe that Trump is the
antichrist. I believe that there's
predictive programming desensitizing us
to prepare us for a one world religion.
I think that Trump is being set up as a
false antichrist decoy so that Satan can
come on the scenes as Christ, a
supernatural being. Satan is a beautiful
angel of light. He's going to come on
the scenes and conquer Trump and be and
everyone's going to believe that Satan
is Christ. Satan knows that Christians
are looking for a fake Christ first, an
antichrist first and then the real
Christ. So therefore, Satan is going to
make a fake Antichrist so that he can
come on the scenes and everyone will
believe that he is the true Christ and
deceive the entire world. Thank you guys
for watching this video. Please share
this with your family and friends so
they can be prepared for the deception
that is soon coming. Jesus is coming
soon. Get your hearts ready. Clean your
house out of all wickedness. Spend these
last days fully dedicated to Christ.
Share this with all your family and
friends. We love you and we thank you.
We'll see you next time on Can of Truth.